c'est faux
bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi la
tacc tech avez vous déjà entendu parler
de l'espace schengen il s'agira de notre
sujet aujourd'hui alors l'espace
schengen c'est quoi il y a une grande
différence lorsque tu passes la
frontière par exemple pour aller en
australie et en allemagne
l'accueil pour aller en australie il te
faut obligatoirement que passeport c'est
à dire une pièce d'identité
mais pour aller en allemagne qu'il
n'aura pas besoin ceci peut s'expliquer
par le fait que la france et l'allemagne
font partie de l'espace schengen tout
comme ils 24 autres membres de cet
espace
l'espace schengen est donc un accord
signé entre plusieurs états qui
souhaitent ouvrir leurs frontières pour
que les citoyens des états membres
puissent circuler librement y voyager
plus facilement
c'est à dire qu'en tant que français qui
peut passer les frontières d'un pays
nombre de cette espèce mini vineux
simple carte d'identité
à ce jour l'espace schengen compte 26
membres et 22 d'entre eux font partie de
l'union européenne et les quatre autres
les quatre autres membres sont des états
associés
il s'agit de la suisse la norvège le
liechtenstein et l'islande
ils ne font pas partie de l'union
européenne c'est quatre pays participent
qu'à l'élaboration des décisions
concernant la coopération schengen mais
sans droit de vote
quelle est l'origine de l'espace
schengen l'espace schengen est né d'un
accord datant de 1985 le pays faute à
l'origine de l'accord de schengen
la france l'allemagne la belgique les
pays bas et le luxembourg
pourquoi on appelle ça l espace schengen
la i do i 5
l'accord a été signé dans le village de
schengen au luxembourg dès la réunion
alors larignon fait partie de l'union
européenne en tant que région kleefstra
périphériques
c'est à dire qu'elle est éloigné du
continent européen
cependant la réunion ne fait pas partie
de l'espace schengen les ressortissants
français ainsi que ceux de l'union
européenne doivent donc se munir d'un
passeport ou d'une carte d'identité pour
passer la frontière pour les
ressortissants des autres pays
un visa est nécessaire attention au
vivat pour la france métropolitaine mais
pas valable pour la réunion étant donné
qu'elle ne fait pas partie de l'espace
schengen
vous l'aurez compris la réunion bien
qu'elle fasse partie de l'union
européenne mais pas membre de l'espace
schengen qui occupent un statut
particulier car elle se situe loin de la
france et de l'union européenne
je vous dis à bientôt dans un nouvel
épisode